so i started angel investing almost one
year ago well i i did it five or eight
companies personally
before that i forget and a couple of
them have turned out to be like
meaningful like turning 20 grand into
like 300 400 500 000 and i'm like holy
this is how it works
and like but like it it sucks for a
while right because you just invest it
you're like well that's money's gone and
you don't ever hear about them and then
you're like oh
nice it works and so i'm like in some of
those cases those are huge markups in
other cases i'm just now experiencing
like two and three and four x markups
and i'm like that's awesome what would
happen if that was had i invested in
this company at a 10 million valuation
instead of a 50 million evaluation that
would have been wild
[Music]
i've noticed that your angel investing
is on a tear our friend suli just said
whatever sean
what did he what did he say whatever
sean joke he was like oh i got this new
brilliant investment strategy uh sean
invests in something and then he tells
me about it two weeks to two months
later and then i paid 10x price for the
same item for the same company yeah it
was great which is and he's like
he was joking obviously obviously that's
not great he's like making fun of
himself because
that's literally what's happened in like
i think six or eight deals now
where i'll i'll even tell him about it
but he just delays responding for a
couple weeks or i forget to tell them
and i tell them or he tells me about the
company a few months later i'm like oh
yeah i invested in that he's like
awesome can you make an intro and i make
the intro and but the price has gone up
like dramatically because the company
has more traction or more whatever
so that's what he was joking about but
how are you getting such good
um i don't know like dude it's amazing
so i feel like there's i think the easy
answer is oh cool i do this podcast and
because of this podcast people come
inbound right the bigger this podcast
gets the more people
uh want you to invest and there's this
great um thing my buddy vishal taught me
when she goes
startups are the only asset class like
real estate doesn't work this way stock
market like in real estate if you want
to buy it you go buy it if you want
stock if you want to buy it you go buy
it startups are the only thing where
even if you want in
you don't just get in the security
selects you the asset selects you just
as much as you're selecting the asset
and that one insight is pretty important
it basically means you need to build
your brand and your like reputation so
that people want you in deals um because
the best deals are all like kind of
like super competitive to get into
um and you want people to when they're
first thinking of an idea to reach out
to you because they know oh you know
like for example i did a great deal
recently and it's so funny you're going
to hate this
it's going to piss you off so much
you've been talking about short-term
rentals
somebody came to me with a short-term
rental startup idea because they thought
i was you or something or somebody who
was like hey
bro why didn't you say that to me well
the by the way the subject line that she
reached out with was last one in it was
like hey i have the smallest bit of
allocation left in this
a company called motherboard you'll love
it because it's it's literally exactly
what you're doing you should get it i'll
enter you
you will get in uh but but basically
what they're doing is you if you own a
bunch of airbnbs which is kind of like a
new market uh it's basically like you're
a property manager so you're more than
just renting out your home or one home
so you have multiple properties but
you're not a traditional property
manager who owns a multi-family you know
like uh building of like 32 units and so
this is for people who run multiple
airbnbs and it's just like it makes your
life way easier as the as the owner of
that and they have like few million
dollars in recurring revenue the
valuation was great founder was really
impressive so i was like oh yeah great
sas software for people who manage
multiple vacation rentals and then
you're over here building short sam
short-term rental club
building this community doing this thing
and i got the benefit because people
thought i was you that's that's one
answer the piss you off answer that's
ridiculous that is a piss me off answer
whatever it is what it is send me
what's the company called can we talk
about it yeah hostfully
host fully well then i can just email
her it's uh is it uh do they have a
bunch of uh vcs behind it or all angels
um i think this rounds a lot of
individuals i'm not sure it was like i
was kind of late to the party so i was
just pretty quick to just be like okay
this makes a lot of sense uh you know
the once once you have revenue and a few
million dollars uh that's recurring and
they really haven't even like figured
out what their marketing strategy is
going to be yet it's like okay that's a
pretty good signal that this is going to
work and uh it's a pretty indispensable
tool for a property owner so i like that
one but i would say okay here's here's
some of the things that have happened
one is
when i share deals with you you share
deals with me my buddy julian shapiro's
shares like some of the best deals um
he's just very active he's very like
consistent with it meaning like every
week he's sending me some good um
that's i would say 40 to 50 of the
portfolio is relationships with friends
who themselves are experts and
specifically people who are experts in
one niche so it's like
we've been doing a bunch of like sales
person software
and it's because we
like have a relationship with craft
ventures who it started by david sacks
he's kind of like the enterprise sas guy
he built yammer sold it for a billion
dollars his fund specifically just
focuses on sas companies
and what you're do
you talk to so david sends you stuff
dave not me particularly so my partner
romine who runs my fund he basically has
a good relationship with somebody at
graph so for example when they're seeing
something good they're just trading
notes all the time and so we're getting
to get in on a lot of their deals so
if even if are they giving you the deal
but do they
do are they giving you the deal because
they like sean or they like romaine
in this case it's rameen because uh he
has that relationship he's catching up
with that guy every two weeks goes get
coffee or whatever it is and but then i
do the same with my guys right so i do
the same with the people in india or
people in southeast asia because i'm
like i think that's where a lot of
opportunity is and that's where i have
the right relationships so we're sharing
stuff uh just amongst that
so
and then the other thing is like themes
so for example once i decide that a
theme is correct uh like worth worth
betting on
what i learned from suli actually is the
level of aggression you need to have
once you decide
x is a good idea you need to go invest
in that company and then like the five
other companies that are like adjacent
to it so for example um
there's this trend of of banking like
neo banks right so this started several
years ago
uh where people basically were like look
banks are something everybody uses but
has super low customer satisfaction
scores like
their apps sucked uh their marketing
sucked so basically people were like
look
we can create like a digital first bank
and this started like new bank is is
probably the best example of this it's
in brazil they're like oh look yeah and
they're about to go pop people are under
bank there so they started a new bank uh
a friend of a friend of mine uh was like
led their investment and now it's a 10
billion dollar company and it has like
millions of customers in brazil and then
the same thing happened in the uk with
revolut and monzo whatever so this idea
of neo-banking basically of
can you make super slick cus like slick
app for customers digitally market to go
get customers and basically you're
building um you're actually not building
the banking part you usually go partner
with like some bank like bbva or
something like that under the hood it's
bbva but the customer relationship is
with uh
with a company that's really good at at
taking care of customers and building
good user experiences anyway so that's
the the short answer is like okay decide
that that's a good idea
um
and that takes many forms so like we
talked about this before like ramp or
brex these are like brexit i think was
the fastest growing yc company in the
last few years and you look at it you
say is this a good idea you say well
what are they actually doing they're
basically giving credit cards to some
group of people that were dissatisfied
with current credit card providers brex
did it for startups
and they get a portion of every time
that card swipes oh interesting so if a
million people are spending a thousand
dollars a year on it and they're keeping
1.3 percent of the interchange fee of
the debit card or whatever you can come
up with some number you say wow this
company is going to get big pretty fast
so we did that math of neo banks how
much is the neo bank customer worth and
how much is a credit card customer worth
and then we went and did it in every
niche we could think of so we we
invested in keep which is doing this for
canada and then we invested in uh pluto
which is doing this in the middle east
but but did you holler at them yeah then
we go search and destroy basically it's
like how do you go hunt for the best
companies that are doing this in in
either this geography or with this
customer base so for example and you
just dm them on twitter probably yeah
exactly we just reach out cold dm and
say hey i'm a believer in this for this
this and this reason what you're doing
looks super interesting would love to
invest and sometimes it comes inbound
sometimes it's oh you got 100 things
inbound but you know what you're looking
for so you quickly pounce on the four
that fit your your thing aren't you out
of money at this point from the fun
though i raised more money because i was
like i was like before i thought
dude uh you know will i get a million
dollars worth of deals every quarter
that are good deals i'm not just trying
to invest in crap so i need to invest in
good deals so i i was like i don't know
how many high quality deals i'll have
and now um
i realized that like whatever i whatever
i had before was too low so now we're
doing almost two million a quarter uh we
raised more money because we just had
better deals
man i because i'm starting so i started
angel investing almost one year ago well
i i did it
five or eight companies person the last
before that i forget and a couple of
them have turned out to be like
meaningful like turning 20 grand into
like 300 400 500 000 and i'm like holy
this is how it works
and like but like it it sucks for a
while right because you just invest it
you're like well that's money's gone and
you don't ever hear about them and then
you're like oh
nice it works and so i'm like in some of
those cases those are huge markups in
other cases i'm just now experiencing
like two and three and four x markups
and i'm like that's awesome what would
happen if that was had i invested in
this company at a 10 million valuation
instead of a 50 million evaluation that
would have been wild and like how do i
do that well one of the reasons so i
hated startup investing for for a while
because i was like you know is this the
best use of time and money dude it feels
like an expensive hobby i'm just
spending money and not getting anything
in return and then i then i realized two
things which is bezos has this quote
which i believe he goes one of the
biggest competitive advantages you can
have is being long-term oriented
basically if you prioritize like if you
have a 10-year view where you're like
okay i'm gonna maximize what i can do in
10 years and the other guy is trying to
make the most they can make
you know for their quarterly earnings
call right this is what this is how
amazon worked right amazon was basically
like we're willing to lose money
to invest so that we provide two-day
shipping instead of seven day shipping
or free two-day shipping or a larger
selection but it's going to cost us more
because we're going to have more
inventory or whatever
so we're going to go into all these
other verticals books cds whatever
they basically said like his strategy
was long term this is going to be the
most valuable strategy short term we're
going to get punished by the market
because our quarterly earnings are not
going to look great
but that turned out to be the like magic
you know the sort of like the biggest
competitive advantage amazon had was
their ability to be long-term oriented i
think this is true just in general which
is if you're competing in somebody who
they need a result in one year and
you're willing to be patient and get the
result in five years seven years or ten
years
you can make bets that they can't make
so that means you get to have lower
priced bets um that will pay off bigger
just over a longer time horizon so i
think if you have the luxury of a
long-term present that's a competitive
advantage that's how startup investing
works is
if you need money or you want you need
to see positive growth in one year
startup investing sucks if you're
willing to play a 10-year game this
could be an awesome game to play and so
do you think that well but do you think
you told me you're like man i think i
could three and a half x my fun because
that's average now it seems like it's
going to be significantly more yeah like
you know you think about kind of like
what's the floor you know i think a
three and a half x would be
you know a a solid outcome but you know
nothing to write home about
um but like with a small fund like ours
you know you could see things where you
can get a 15x you can get a 20x there
are literally crypto small funds like
ours that that have had 100x the 100x
the fund in in the period of time right
so so you know you shouldn't really the
ceiling is high
um but but the floor is is pretty
reasonable so the first thing was okay
long-term oriented is a competitive
advantage i i like startup investing for
that reason the second one is
um
you want to do things that compound so
for example if i wanted to beat the
market in the stock market right i want
to beat the s p 500 i need to have
proprietary like intelligent i need to
be smarter than anybody else about
something
and i think just being smarter at a game
where money's on the line is just really
hard to do
whereas if you do um
if you basically say hey
my advantage comes from my reputation or
my my network of people that i know
that's just gonna compound every year
the more deals i share with you the more
deals you're going to share with me the
more companies i have that are winners
that's going to make it easier for me to
get into the next winner or for founders
to come reach out to me because they'll
say oh i saw you did these five indian
unicorns i'm an india i want to be the
next one of them so you should can you
invest in me
so compounding also comes into play here
in a way that doesn't happen in the
stock market and doesn't even really
happen in real estate real estate has it
to an extent but but not in the same way
as how fast your reputation can compound
and start investing so anyways those are
my two reasons why
i now actually view startup startup
investing as a as a game worth playing
because it it uses two of the super
powers that uh that i believe in that i
think most people undervalue
is it gonna what do you think will earn
more the ecom thing or this angel
investing thing uh probably for me
personally the ecom thing because i just
own the majority of that company so you
know
if it sells for 50 million dollars or
100 million dollars you know i'll own
the majority of it but uh whereas with
startup investing you know
it's like my fund invests a hundred
thousand dollars we own point eight
percent of this startup i personally
have twenty percent of the carry but
then i share with romine and ben and
zach so i personally own
14 point something percent of the carry
or whatever sure so it's not like you
know you're owning a slice of a slice of
something big versus just owning them
you know how it is owning the majority
of something that sells for a decent
chunk is is just better financially
it's so much better and
yeah i think that whenever people raise
money i'm like are you sure man you
might be able to sell this for 50
million dollars and you'll make more
money than if you raise money and sell
for 500. yeah exactly now you know but i
have to operate that other business
whereas startup investing is like you
know a joy right you just read about
cool ideas you meet awesome founders and
you say yes you write the check and then
they go do the hard work so it's you
know just a different thing
[Music]
you